well you checked uh Roddy off the list
of artists that people want to see you
work with is there anybody else you
really want to work with it for whatever
reason it just hasn't aligned yet uh
nobody specifically I mean I always say
for real but that's like more so I want
him to Executive produce a project later
down the line if if I'm able to if he's
able to but uh nobody specifically right
now I'm trying to focus on myself yeah
nobody on the r b side
nah pretty much work with a lot of
people I gotta get back to the Blast
story you've been on probation recently
for sure yeah I mean I've been going for
I've been I've been feeling like T-Pain
last year
feature crazy feature crazy nowadays
let's say major label calls it's a new
artist they signed you have no idea who
it is but they're on Atlantic and they
want that blast sauce that [__]
what's that heading for uh you know I
never charge for a feature ever ever no
really so you're doing it only if you
truly want I truly like the song you
have to like the song you have to like
the artist yeah I'm talking about up
front it's a backhand cause but if I
like the song I'm not going to give you
that hassle you feel me the back end is
just like uh the bag or is it the maybe
it may be the video the plug and maybe
the the Wardrobe for the video things of
that nature you feel me you still gotta
show up as blast I'm still a brand I'm
still a company but on the front end I'm
not gonna be like I need 15 just to
record the first I need you know yo it
sucks too because a lot of artists will
pay that to these features and then this
song doesn't get clear yeah
stick out the money already hey hey get
your money how you get it couldn't be me
though what about you and T Payne
that'll be crazy hmm I love T-pain have
you seen his uh any of his covers he
just did a whole cover album yeah I've
been watching that he didn't get the uh
uh Ozzy Osbourne War Pigs yeah he did uh
he did a lot of Sam Cook Sam Cook he did
Chris Stapleton the country guy
oh come in yeah T-Pain and Legend you
guys have never connected never can I
think we were supposed to I think I know
his manager actually but
and never got on the table officially
you gotta make it happen man yeah
because you're kind of like the Hook guy
now you know yeah I need some songs I
need to ask him a thousand questions
when I did the video with Rick Ross I
asked him a thousand questions what
questions did you ask Rick Ross I was
like what did you do with your first
million what do you say it was like the
first thing I did I saved it
but he was telling me he was like
because I told him I lived in L.A he was
like that's the worst place to buy real
estate get something in Atlanta Atlantis
for sale it's a lot of land so also the
state taxes here suck yeah
tell me about it are you realizing that
now that you're rich
[Laughter]
I wouldn't say that but you got that guy
Vic over there who'll give you some
terrible tax advice according to Tech
that's my [__] went viral you could
write your jewelry you know how many
CPAs
he cleared it up on the last interview
you know what you got to do you got to
set up the address in Nevada
buy a house out there
just let it sit or just have some people
rent it but all the bills are in your
name hey I'll take all the advice and
then you paste no state tax because
Nevada's that's what you do
no but a rapper who you have a lot of
songs with does that
um yeah
he's from L.A and he likes a lot of
songs more than two no I think you only
have one or two with them okay I think
ish whatever yeah not a lot of